♫ ["The End of the World"
performed by Skeeter Davis] ♫
♫ Why does the sun
go on shining? ♫
♫ Why does the sea
rush to shore? ♫
♫ Don't they know
it's the end of the world? ♫
[Distant rumbling]
♫ 'Cause you don't
love me anymore ♫
SERSI
It's beautiful.
Isn't it?
[Music echoing]
♪♪
AJAK
We have watched...
...and guided.
We have helped them
progress,
and seen them...
...accomplish wonders.
♪♪
AJAK
Throughout the years,
we have never
interfered.
Until now.
♪♪
♫ It ended when
you said goodbye ♫
IKARIS
Thank you for this.
GILGAMESH
Oh, you're welcome.
SPRITE
So now that Captain Rogers and Iron Man
are both gone, who do you
think's gonna lead the Avengers?
IKARIS
I could lead them.
[Laughing]